so to provide some opening remarks to
the conference we're pleased to have dr.
John crystal the chair of the department
of psychiatry here at Yale and the
Robert L McNeil junior professor of
translational research and professor of
Neurobiology he's also the chief of
psychiatry at yeaah new haven hospital
and director of several research centers
here at you please joining me in
welcoming dr. crystal it's a pleasure on
behalf of the department of psychiatry
and the medical school here at yale to
welcome all of you to our community this
is a very special conference that we've
come to look forward to every year and I
want to thank Emily and Seth and the
national education alliance for
borderline personality disorder dr.
Hoffman who's who has been very
important critical to this conference to
to bring this conference to Yale into
our community borderline personality
disorder is a is a very problematic very
misunderstood and vary from a clinical
perspective very challenging disorder so
I I'm thrilled to see this wonderful set
of presentations and discussions that
will help to advance our thinking in our
ability to help people and families
where people have borderline personality
disorder you know in our in this state
and in this time we can't but help be
reminded about how active we have to be
in advocating for people with mental
illness that they should be able to get
access to the help and services that
they need and that there be support for
research to advance the state of the
knowledge about both about understanding
the problems and developing new ways to
treat these problems in our state we
we've been dealing with the state budget
and the
impact of that on potentially on the
access to care and the and research
support so being coming together in this
in this kind of context is not only a
reminder about how the people who are
suffering need to be able to get access
to the support that they need but how
actively we all have to be to ensure
that that access can continue in the
current context so this is a wonderful
conference we're so thrilled that you
all can come together to work on this
very important problem and I hope you
have a wonderful day thank you